we just watched the premiere episode of
gotham
and uh we're gonna start talking about
in a second before we do if you don't
want to have anything about this first
episode ruined for you you might want to
move along otherwise stick around and
you can see what we thought about it and
what did you think good sir
yeah i i think i i'm in agreeance with
that we're all done thank you for
joining us
for should we talk about the premise but
like before we even get into the sure
why not let's
let's start with the base level on this
thing so
if you saw the dark knight rises and you
liked the 90 minutes where batman wasn't
saving the people of gotham city
this show is right for the show is for
you it's batman's world without batman
and that made me nervous from the get-go
yeah i know
long before the show long before i ever
saw the show i i thought this was doomed
to failure once the show started i was
enjoying the show for about the first 20
minutes
and then i feel like right at the
halfway point it took
a bizarre turn
i felt like they were they were
approaching it in a very sort of
standard formulaic police procedural way
that was working
um and then they decided it needs to be
a bigger conspiracy but they had no idea
how to do that yeah they they've made
this strange decision
to take a number of things and turn them
into mysteries where there's no reason
to have that be a mystery like it's it's
obviously it's going to be a mystery who
knows how long they're stringing out who
actually killed bruce wayne's parents
and why
except that that's never mattered it's
the least interesting mystery gotham
city the place itself is responsible for
the death of the wings that's why it
needed to create batman so i don't need
them to find out who
who killed them well the other day like
they've tossed these hints at some sort
of weird backstory for um
jim gordon's future wife barbara that
was precisely the point when the the
show took
like kind of went off the rails it
started getting weird right jim gordon
the main character his girlfriend soon
to be wife barbara
has
a
past lover in detective renee montoya
um who is a lesbian in the comics but
that is only introduced in order to
create this weird division
and make renee seem like jealous and
petty it seemed like it was just a plot
point because they needed to give gordon
a reason to suspect that there was a
frame job yeah that was really the point
where i started picking apart even what
had gone on up to that point yeah
because i
i don't i don't like this jim gordon
because and to kind of illustrate why i
have to i have to reference gary oldman
now i'm gonna try and do this not in a
way that i'm like he was the best and it
must be like him but i need to
illustrate what he did right to
illustrate what this guy's doing wrong
what i hoped this show would be is kind
of in the embodiment of a number of
scenes that gordon has in batman begins
sure he's got this line you know i'm i'm
no rat but in a town this bent who is
there to rat to so i liked this notion
of the dynamic of a guy who's a good guy
and who's trying to be a good guy but
who knows is completely aware and has no
illusions about the world he's living
he's resigned to the idea exactly can't
change that yes he's going to be the
best guy he can under the world's worst
circumstances that he knows he can't
change right what they've gone for
instead is the more traditional i am
righteous and upright and i will fight
this corruption i'm like oh
come on that i mean it's not as
interesting it brings up a problem again
going to the very premise of this was
jim gordon couldn't change gotham he
needed batman to do that and if you're
having a show without batman then jim
can't succeed
or if he does if he makes
gotham city a better place
then you've invalidated the need for
batman
yeah pretty much so i don't i don't see
how they can win all right so getting
back to the point another
problem with the character of jordan and
this goes to
what's at the heart of the show is
gordon and bullock their partnership
two very different characters which
they've they depicted them as having
very different characteristics
but the actors also play them very
different intensity levels yeah
but usually when you're talking to
someone when you're interacting with
another person you match their intensity
if something is how it's raising their
voice
you tend to start raising your voice
and that that's a natural prediction and
that never happened in this show they
were always on different wavelengths and
it seems like almost everybody who was
in the show was just on their own
wavelength and it
it bore no relation to whatever else was
going on around them everyone just kind
of picked pic this is what i am for this
scene i'm like well you know everyone
else is going for no no i'm this right
yeah i noticed that when it seemed like
jada pinkett smith's character was
channeling michael kenneth williams from
the wire and boardwalk empire
i was like oh i've seen this
that said i actually kind of liked it
she was one of the highlights for me
that she was fun to watch it was a
watchful character i had a couple of
things
that that i liked they were few but i
had a couple things okay let's let's
talk about the pros all right i liked
her
i i have to assume that she's not gonna
stick around past this season at any
rate because she's a made-up character
for this show and she's obviously there
to get knocked out and to have a more
recognizable person take her place in
that place in the crime rate she's on
borrow time yes which is a shame i
actually
surprisingly like the penguin
he was the standout yeah and they made
him a much more vicious physically sort
of visceral
predatory character which yeah i i was
surprised they took him that far this
quickly it it happened a little faster
than i saw but what i liked about it was
we got his initial introduction and he
was this sort of sniveling like sort of
backstabbing it's a little bit of a
stock character when you're doing a um
any kind of organized crime movie he's
the obvious person who's got a backstab
to work his way up the lines but these
sort of characters are always they're
always sniveling they're weak they're
meager but to have that contrast with
just how vicious
he is at the same time i'm like that is
actually pretty interesting production
value i mean they they it looks good i
mean it's a good looking show from the
opening shots of the city i mean they
they made it look like a lived-in place
with a lot of color contrasts sort of
like the bright lights of like the
the street with these high-rises and
everything other other pros other things
other pros um i kind of like the guy
they got for carmine falcone it was a
late edition it was filming yeah they
revealed that didn't need to be in this
episode he seemed just way too forward
with jim gordon for somebody he's never
met he's telling this character a lot
for the sake of exposition there was a
lot of that in general there was a lot
of characters saying things that i'm
like why would you ever say that i think
for me best epitomized by
gordon telling
a young
preteen
angry bruce wayne oh the guy who
who the papers said killed your parents
and who i i helped take down didn't
actually kill him it's somebody else i
don't know who it is and that
immediately follows with don't tell
anybody yeah please i'm i'm asking you
to keep your mouth shut about this
horrible conspiracy that i just
converted confined to a legal minor in
front of this
british butler who's shown a strange
kind of hostility towards me in the two
minutes that i've known him yeah there
were times where i felt like this show
was going through rewrites while they
were filming it the big one is
in the middle of in the middle of the
show there's this discussion where
gordon and bullock realize they
solved the case incorrectly they got it
bad
that the guy they thought killed the
waynes might be innocent that it might
have been a frame job
and then it becomes this whole fear and
paranoia that they actually killed an
innocent man and that they could lose
their jobs for that
except forgetting the circumstances of
how the shooting went down that the man
was about to stab gordon with a knife in
an alley after shooting at him any
police force in the world would consider
that a righteous shooting when bullock
takes him out i feel like it could have
worked slightly better
if there could have been some breathing
room right it was very rapid fire but
the thing is unless
unless you're doing law and order
which was a show literally constructed
to we solved this case by the end of
this hour right unless you're doing that
you need to slow down a little bit so
that we have weight to the proceedings
and we get a feel for how this works i
feel like the place this first episode
needs to end
is the realization that the case isn't
closed that they got the wrong guy that
you know and that would have given them
enough time to go through the basic
logistics of the police investigation
and then there's this reveal of wait
that's not the wrong guy
it might have been the police themselves
who who framed this who set this all up
yeah and that sort of blows up gordon's
world and that's a great place to end
the first episode yeah and when that's
if they'd taken that half hour and made
it a full hour we they we could have had
a legitimate procedural right which we
did which we didn't have either because
that's the thing if the pitch is
gotham city as procedural
it wasn't a procedural do you intend to
watch the next episode
possibly out of morbid curiosity me
catching the second episode of this has
has just dropped several priority
notches and depending on how much free
time i have i might not even bother my
basic feel is that if you're going to do
tv shows of these characters that you
are also planning on putting in movies
right
this sort of approach where the tv show
is completely different from the film
character is the way to go sure
versus what i'm afraid what they're
doing with the with the flash and green
arrow which is that they're doing them
straight which means if we ever get them
on me on in movies as well we're also
going to get them straight and then
you've got two competing visions that
you can't help but compare right and i
think that's dangerous but so i i like
the angle that they came at this app
from
i don't like the results though so you
know just so we can get into crazy
stupid wild speculation
throw up just throw a name out there who
actually killed the waynes either pulled
the trigger or had it ordered alfred
alfred okay you heard it here first
alfred pennyworth orchestrated the
killing of the waynes there you go
so thank you for joining us and until
next time this council is adjourned